Я відчував, що я піду на війну. Це було зрозуміло.
Якщо повномасштабна війна - всі йдуть на війну.
Я знав одну просту річ: у мене був білий білет, я міг якось домогтися, сказати, що я непридатний, я маю перетнути кордон.
Але я знав, що якщо я це зроблю - я не зможу спати там.
Я, Стороженко Віктор, я би не зміг там спати, жити, їсти, я би відчував себе чмом.
Я жив у Криму до 2014-го. Там вся сім’я була, там кватири були, там друзі були. І там пройшло дитинство і весь свідомий вік.
Крим для мене і особливо Севастополь - дуже неоднозначна штука.
Там, по суті, постійно був інформаційний простір російський.
І тому вони дуже піддавалися тим настроям, які панували в Росії.
У Росії якийсь час панувала ця штука, коли вони ходили і кричали: "Россия - для русских. Ану-ка давай отсюда".
І Крим теж хворів цією штукою. Тому в четвертому класі мені довелося важкувато.
Мене били дев’ятикласники просто тому, що я наполовину африканець. Це було модно.
У мене мама патріотична і тітка патріотична.
У мене тітка була російським філологом, їй 40 років було, пішла вчитися заочно на українського філолога,
перевчилася і викладала українську філологію в Криму. До війни.
Після 2014 року всі батьки, всі ми виїхали. Мама не могла там залишатися.
24 лютого зруйнувало моє життя. Просто моє життя отак от посипалося, просто посипалося у мене на очах.
Бо я збирався взагалі йти з акторської професії. І я отримав пропозицію від ІТ-компанії. І 24-го числа я мав нести документи в ІТ-компанію.
У ці вихідні я випускав виставу свою як режисер. Тобто я хотів красиво піти із акторства.
Я чую вибухи, я кажу: "Збирай, буди сина". А моя дружина, ще треба зрозуміти, що ми за три дні до війни зрозуміли, що вона вагітна.
Я пішов у військкомат, мені відмовили, бо в мене "білий" квиток. Я хворів в дитинстві 6 разів на менінгіт.
Три актори, знайомі мої, були в "Легіоні Свободи".
Я запитав: "Мене візьмуть?". Вони сказали: "Приїжджай, візьмуть". І мене взяли.
Я розумів, що мені дуже страшно, я не військовий, а все несеться. Були якісь тактичні заняття, чистка зброї, ми ночували там.
Ми ходили на зачистки, заходили в села звільнені, розтяжки, шукали спорядження їхнє, докази.
-Що знайшов, Мавр? – Ми тут знайшли підсумок їхній.
Але це ми ще були добровольчим батальйоном. Ми ж потім стали Нацгвардією.
Ми вже під Рубіжне під’їхали, приєдналися до них і все, і пішло - Сєвєродонецьк, "Азот", Лисичанськ, Зайцеве.
Ми приїхали в Сєвєродонецьк. 20 хвилин - і почався стрілковий бій. І це був стрілковий бій, коли ти бачиш ворога. Ніяких перекидувань там не було.
От ти бачиш ворога. 50 метрів, 20 метрів - ти бачиш ворога. Почався "пейнтбол". Тільки уяви: справжніми кулями.
Коли ми приїхали в Лисичанськ і збиралися в Сєвєродонецьк, нам сказали: у вас задача протримати його хоча б 7 днів.
А батальйон «Свободи» тримав Сєвєродонецьк місяць. Майже місяць - 24 дні.
Тому реально ми відтягнули час, ми дали часу підготуватися до певних речей більше, ніж треба.
Піхота - це м'ясо. Треба це розуміти.
Піхота просто помічає рубежі. Що таке піхота, коли на тебе летить міна? Що може піхота в окопах?
Просто сидіти і отримувати "люлей". Все. Щоб просто там знали: а там - наше.
Вони залишали трупи. Мені трупи снилися. Мені після Лисичанська… я спав, мені снилися трупи. Вони гнили на перехресті.
Коли я потрапив у бій під Зайцевим - я захотів у Лисичанськ на відпочинок. Бо оце було пекло. Нас там просто рівняли з землею.
Я не знаю, як це показати, бо я здам позиції. Вони реально залишають по собі випалену траву. Зараз я зайду в дим. Отак може покажу трішки. Все горить.
Там є відео, де я знімаю, в Інстаграмі. Насправді там я змирився зі своєю смертю.
Я думав: "Та я вже помру в цьому бою". Це був пекельний бій. Нас просто рівняли із землею всім: запальними мінами,
касетним  мінами, звичайними мінами всіх калібрів, гради, танки, авіація. Просто кожен сектор. Горіло все.
7 годин триває артобстріл і оцей бій. 7 годин. Я вже не можу просто. Я так втомився, і мене прикантузило трішки, бо прильоти сталися прямо поруч.
Я працював з колишнім чоловіком моєї сестри, він дуже крутий насправді. Ми з ним, вперше в житті тримаючи міномет, навелися спочатку на окоп,
потрапили поруч з окопом, вони забігли в бліндаж, і прямим потраплянням накрили їх в бліндажі - і всі "200-ті".
Всі, хто був у бліндажі, "200-ті"… Це стало переломною точкою в бою. І після цього послали вже зачистку.
Я сиджу в будинку, де немає навіть даху, він зруйнований. Але мені треба тримати позиції. Жесть.
Нас троє. Нас комбат подав на нагороду.
Поки ми стріляли, ми з четвертого разу потрапили, з четвертого пострілу, нас вичислили і накрили.
І такий – пффф (звук прильоту). І насправді мені пощастило. Бо уламок увійшов отак, вдарився і вийшов сюди.
А якщо б він трішки вище пару міліметрів, то у мене не було б ока.
(бабах) Зараз працює танк.
Я бачив Бога. Коли зі мною падали снаряди, поруч зі мною входили в землю і не вибухали. І це було дуже багато разів.
І мене поранило. Я дуже довго їхав і думав, чому, за що мене поранило? Мені здавалося, що це якесь покарання.
Наступний день цю позицію накрило авіаударом. Я довго думав, що якби мене не поранило, можливо, я був би на тій позиції.
У мене стався нервовий зрив. І після нервового зриву мене у психіатричну лікарню запроторили.
Як тільки я закривав очі – я чув приліт міни.
Покажу вам: випалена земля. Тут було стільки зелені, стільки зелені. Все не можу навколо показати. Бляха, зараз буде падати міна.
Мені лікар сказав, що швидше за все ти вже ідеш через психіку свою  обмеженої придатності. Тобто мене не пустять на нуль.
Якщо випишуть обмеженим - буду займатися, чим скажуть, возити продовольство. Треба. А хто, якщо не я?
А треба буде поїхати на передову - значить поїду на передову.
Знаєш, є таке в українців: Хіба маєш? Мусиш.
Я український націоналіст.
-	Слава Україні! – Героям слава!
Людина, яка любить свою націю, яка любить свою історію, вивчає свою історію, любить свою мову.
Якщо б ми були нацистською державою - ми б поводили себе як Росія, яка є нацистською державою,
яка від’єднується віх усіх і вважає себе титульною расою.
Вони програють. Вони вже програють.